Most concisely, an operating system contains code to access the physical
resources, that is contained in a computer system, and arbitrate among competing
requests for those hardware resources, coming
from multiple applications that may be
running simultaneously on the processing platform.
So in other words, the operating
system is just a program, like any other program you may have written. Okay,
slightly more complex than a hello world
program, I'm being facetious here, intentionally. But you
get the point. It's a matter of climbing the latter of programming, just like,
a ball player may start from t-ball to little league to the minor league and
then to majors, you can also do it. If Microsoft can do it, you can do it. If
you can write a hello, world program today, you can eventually write an
entire operating system. So what the operating system provides are well-defined
APIs for accessing the hardware resources that are managed by the operating
system. And these resources are provided as operating
system services through this well defined interfaces, and an application may
make a request to the operating system for such hardware resources through this
well defined api interface. And the application, via the response from the
operation system gets the services from
the operating system via these API codes.